here's the story from timcast.com I'm
just going to let you guys know I'm not
reading a single quote from this man yay
yay calls Hitler a cool leader and makes
other anti-semitic comments during
Infowars appearance you can't say that
out loud that's what yay was saying he
was doing the was it Mussolini made the
trains run on time thing that whole bit
yeah that whole argument it's just let
me just play I'm gonna play Clips I
gotta I gotta play this clip because I
just it's just crazy so let's let's is
the audio good I like Hitler I don't
like Hitler and I know you're trying to
be shocking with that I'm not trying to
be shocking I like Hitler I do not I the
the Holocaust is not what happened let's
look at the facts of that and Hitler has
a lot of redeeming qualities oh my God I
understand he's trying to do the
Christian forgiveness Arc of like
everybody has Humanity in them and it's
coming out wrong it's coming out blunt
and people aren't going to unders I
don't think people are understanding I
don't I don't think that's what he's
doing in at all let me let me play
another clip for you you know it's like
he had a really cool outfit and stuff
and he was a really good architect and
uh so you're in love with the with the
with the with the arc the the look of it
and he didn't kill six million Jews
that's just like factually incorrect
guys get the Ronald Reagan clip they
showed me yesterday sorry go ahead
Ronald Reagan said that too well I think
Hitler did Target and kill some people
Obama killed Palestinians I don't I I
Alex
that was I don't know man come on Alex
Alex Jones being like I think he did
Target and kill some people like I I
don't know like this may be a bit
personal but I think Luke had family
members were personally targeted by that
yeah yeah my you know family died
we're not Jewish we weren't Jewish but
my great-grandmother ended up in the
shootoff concentration camps my great
grandfather on my mother's and father's
side died Fighting the War uh we still
don't know if it was the Russians or the
the Nazis but obviously the Nazis
provoke that situation in Poland so yeah
I mean I had a lot of family members
pass away uh from from you know a lot of
crazy stuff throughout you know polish
history but I don't want to be using
that as as a way to just say I'm
offended because you know obviously
these are in in yeah insane comments but
I don't want to use my family's history
to add to the insanity of today I just
want to make this point though because
when I saw that clip I saw it on YouTube
tube and then a recommended video is
Norm McDonald talking about Adolf Hitler
joking about it and you know he said it
first you know the more you look into
Adolf Hitler you know the less I seem to
like him and uh you know I just I just
can't imagine that like
Kanye did some research oh you know what
oh actually he uh he designed the
Porsche he's good he made an engine he
made some you know scientists do this so
he said he invented the microphone yeah
I'm true yeah yeah I mean it's like you
know I
it's never a good look to idolize or say
anything positive but Adolf Hitler is so
obvious I don't know why he's doing that
it's not just shocking I think he's
seriously confused or under some sort of
hypnosis uh I wanted to address you know
you said insane and this this part was
making earlier
he I think he's extremely wrong Hitler
didn't invent the microphone maybe
there's some like there maybe maybe he's
expressing whatever idea he's trying to
express incorrectly I think he said he
invented the microphone that I use and
he was like Serge pointed out he's is a
piece of technology in the microphone
that lets you hear vibration close to
the throat so tank commanders could use
them uh well it's like the the tank mics
in World War II were like on the throw
and that's something they did invent
it's not I don't know what he's saying
that's the only thing I could think of
watching it's like maybe is that what
he's talking about but yeah I don't so I
just want to say there's a difference
between being crazy because everyone's
saying he's having a psychotic break and
I'm like okay first of all he does that
thing he pulls out a net and a Yoo-hoo
bottle and he's like net and Yoo-hoo or
whatever and he's going like we're gonna
come take your kids and I'm like that's
that's performative like if I saw
someone doing a weird show on the street
so I wouldn't say they're crazy I'd be
like like a performer is doing a
performance if he believes things that
are are just you know grossly incorrect
or he's expressing them incorrectly or
he's praising people that are very bad
that to me is not a sign of mental
illness it's a sign of a person who is
wrong about a thing right and at any
time
I just want to make one point here
because many times he was also just
going to Nick and didn't have the
answers and you could see he was kind of
filling in a lot of blanks here but he
wasn't even you know he was talking
about also about Planned Parenthood and
he's trying to equate different things
to different scenarios but if he really
would have understood the situation he
would have understood that Margaret
Sanger the founder of Planned Parenthood
was a big American eugenicist that
inspired the Nazis that inspired you
know Hitler with his larger uh Final
Solution Eugenics depopulation control
agenda that he implemented so if he's
really against all that stuff he would
have obviously seen the parallels here
so I I don't know some people are saying
he's just trying to be controversial
some people are saying he's crazy some
people are saying he's just filled with
hate uh whatever whatever it is
everyone's talking about it I just want
to point out who knows exactly why
because there's a very few people that
there's documentaries where they say
that there's some evil cabal that is
ruining the world and that Hitler was
supposedly stomping that out and that's
why they in his head he thinks that that
was a good thing yeah but when you look
at it that's what he thinks it is
happening and that's what some people
think out there and I want to break that
that's incorrect as I understand that's
what he thinks yeah but then it was
Prescott Bush the Rockefellers and it's
not one and a lot of group of people a
lot of our bigger Industries especially
in the United States that was financing
Germany
um and you know there's also you know
the Soros thing the Arnold
Schwarzenegger thing operation paper
clip there's a lot of things that
intertwine here that that show us that
obviously there's something bigger here
historically but but he's not bringing
that up he's bringing up a lot of things
to try to provoke people to try to get
some kind of emotion out of people to
try to get people angry to try to get
them stirred up here what's the reason
what do you guys think Alex Jones said I
know you're trying to be shocking he
says no I'm not yeah he
I don't know man uh just what's the
reason why is he doing it because
obviously he's he's Kanye doing that
yeah
it's personal I mean some things it's
just something happened to him you know
by losing his bank account and I don't
know if that he was on the edge because
you know when you get you're trying to
say it's not mental illness Tim but you
can get like in these hyper focused
rabbit holes because I don't know what
do you guys think he drinks is he on
drugs and I'm not saying I have no idea
and I know I know from pretty sure Nick
or my I don't know if they use drugs but
I'm pretty sure they don't he said on
the show that at some point he found
himself drinking and like you know
having orgies and then he realized like
he shouldn't be drinking because the
king shouldn't drink or something like
that and so then he stopped so he
doesn't drink like when he tweeted he
said when he tweeted the deathcon thing
he was drinking and he was drunk oh he
was and then he said because the Bible
says you can drink but the Bible says
the king shouldn't drink and then I
realized I shouldn't well his mental
health is never going to get back
together so you think it's mental health
or do you think he's trying to spread
hate or do you think he's legitimate
crazy or what's the solution because it
seems like you're saying ain't crazy I
mean I think it's a little bit of both I
mean you know they say that that like
you know a lot of these School shooters
happen everybody's like oh what's on the
FBI's radar this and that you can get
radicalized by the stuff you see in your
search engine and your algorithm by the
stuff that you've repeatedly watched and
the stuff that gets right but you don't
see this stuff what what yay is saying
every photo I see of him he's on his
phone he's on his phone and I'm a guy
that's addicted to my phone because I do
stuff my phone I had a little clip
sometimes and it's a film something that
I'm always on my phone and so I know
what it's like to live in there so I'm
sure he's always in a rabbit hole he's
always on a plane he's like what oh my
gosh when he was here we were talking to
him he was on his phone the whole time
and we were having a conversation and
then he just kept this is a blast you
know this guys this is a Black Mirror
when you look at this phone guys look at
this this is an evil device this is what
basically the transhumanist agenda like
this is it has an apple on the back of
it that's happening for a reason
I know it's anecdotal to say that
because it's also anecdotal say there's
fluoride in the water but yet you use
ice at every restaurant yada yada yada
like it's just still though this guys
and I'm addicted to it so I am the
biggest hypocrite it's terrible for your
brain
you're pointing out the SIM the the
symbolism of of an apple like the Garden
of Eden and the Apple that was eating is
bitten and then yeah yeah I got the vibe
that Kanye was or yeah was uh just
totally mentally broken and totally but
mentally broken when they took his bank
account down like he realized oh even if
I have 500 million tomorrow they can
snap a finger and it goes to zero or
something they got money he's still got
money he's got hundreds of millions he
said I think that was like a black pill
and now he's like thrashing around
trying to figure out what to do and he's
gone full Christ Consciousness he's like
I'm gonna be in full forgiveness of
every demon that's ever lived and that's
the Christ he's not going after every
demon he's going on one specific
cultural reference which he knows pisses
a lot of people off the main one well
because he's doing the old talk about
what you can't say but if I was not
saying Genghis Khan he's not saying
Stalin he's not saying Mao zetong but if
he was if he was but this is what some
people are trying to excuse this
Behavior as oh he's trying to piss
everyone off just to be more christ-like
just and there's is no way he's doing
that because if he did he would have
done it from a different way he would
have done it from a way of compassion
rather than trying to stir up a beehive
I don't know you're not always when
you're in a manic State you don't always
go for compassion if I was his manager
if I was Milo I would say listen you're
not gonna be able to go on the campaign
Trail and actually articulate these very
nuanced subjects that are very very hard
because they're not black and white
they're very gray and he's not going to
be able to articulate that but his best
weapon and even said that he stinks in
music he thinks in harmony he's you know
you know Melodies so he should if he
really like wants to expose A New World
Order he should have an anti-new World
Order album make that go number one but
that's not what he wants he wants a Ubi
he wants sustainable government housing
for everyone
let me get my tin foil hat because this
is what Tavistock the Tavistock
Institute basically they you know they
do a lot of the Mind Control a lot of
the MK Ultra experimenting and they have
music that they use as propaganda
because they've actually done testing
that they know what harmonies and
Melodies are actually pleasurable for
our ears so it's like these places can
actually create music that is like
addicting for us like that's why these
same artists are able to recreate you
know pop hits because a lot of them are
using the same Melody patterns like you
can actually look into it Tavistock like
they've actually had soldiers they put
them on drugs they put them sober they
had them listen to the music they tested
their heart rate they tested how they
feel if they want to dance if not so
they basically can have a cheat code and
I'm saying Kanye West I know you want to
talk real quick could hack into that
that's the only thing he can I can do
him saying uh the Nuance of the month
but he can't you know speak for himself
to save his life but a song that's the
only way I think he would be effective
in getting his message across there's
that viral video where this producer is
like here's I make a pop song and they
take like a young model they auto-tune
her voice then they he like breaks down
the structure of what pop music is they
even have our AIS that can auto-generate
Melodies and beats and then they craft
it into the perfect pop song
what Kanye is doing culturally is he's
speaking the harmony but there is no
Melody and people don't hear they don't
know what the melody is so it sounds
confusing like what he's saying about
yes there is goodness in people that we
think are evil that is like a harmonic
to well let's start with what we know
which is addicted to amphetamines
genocide against our culture let me let
me give a shout out to Ian yin yang
you've seen it right it's the you know
the White and the black there's a dot in
each of them of the opposing color
symbolizing that within light there is
dark within dark there is light and the
Sun and Moon right right it's the
duality of life but it's all but the
point I'm trying to make is that people
often don't realize it doesn't just mean
one against the other and I mean it also
means within the dark there is a Light
Within light there is dark that being
said I I can respect that point I think
we all understand the Nuance because the
conversation's been had about you know
even Hitler liked dogs Mussolini made
the transfer on time but there's a
reason why we specifically highlight the
really evil things that came about from
what they've done because that is the
the the the bulk of their character yes
we get it humans share certain traits
that we we like but we're talking about
the specific unique components of a
particular individual and the bad things
they've done you know what I mean yeah
but it's weird that he's like
attributing things like the microphone
which Neumann made in 1928 in Germany
1930 I don't know someone can tell me in
the chat but Neumann made the microphone
why is attributing that and Hugo Boss
and Volkswagen to to Adolf or
architecture did he says I don't know
but if you wrapped it nobody would care
but because he's trying to say it then
he has to be like hey hey look shout out
to uh Public Enemy because when I was a
little kid they had that song in Tony
Hawk Pro Skater 2 Bring the Noise where
they did a team up with Anthrax and one
of the verses in that song because I
used to know all the words is
farrakhan's a prophet that I think you
ought to listen to what he can say to
you
and I didn't know what that meant when I
was a little kid and that's in Tony
Hawk's Pro Skater that's one of the
greatest games of all time and then in
part two and then I grow up and I'm like
I wonder what that means and I look into
and I go holy what was in this game wow
dude and you loved it it was a song it
was like Turn It Up Bring the Noise and
I'm like yeah I'm like I had no idea
what it meant I think the one of the
problems that Kanye has been having is
the same as a similar problem what
Hitler was having which is that some
people were screwing with them and they
were Jewish so he blamed the entire
Jewish religion I had to say this and I
hope this doesn't get me in trouble
though but it does prove Kanye a little
right as soon as they take away his bank
account I mean you know I mean but it's
this is the problem
because what's happening is like you had
30 dogs and 29 of them were Brown it
doesn't mean that most dogs are brown no
what what country is saying is abharan
discussing but it's just you know you
know him getting shut down and now it's
like I think he's doubling down the the
Trump where now he can't go back and be
like oh I didn't mean this I meant you
know there's just these few guys that's
he's just gone too far thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time